. Auto. Automobil. Wer war eigentlich der Erste, der statt Automobil Auto gesagt hat? Das war genau der Typ, der statt Flugzeug Flug gesagt hat? Nee, der bei Schuhen, die du ja in die Schuhkartons packst, auf die Idee gekommen ist, beide quasi entgegengesetzt. Das ist eine geile Idee, ne? So dass die genau reinpassen in diesen quadratischen Kasten und nicht auf welcher Platz verbrauchen. Da dachte ich mir auch so, der Erste, der das gemacht hat, hat die Schuhe so entgegengesetzt. Das ist eine geile Idee, ne? So, dass die genau reinpassen in diesen quadratischen Kasten und nicht weniger Platz verbrauchen. Da dachte ich mir auch so, der Erste, der das gemacht hat, quasi die Schuhe so entgegengesetzt ineinander reingeschoben hat, da haben alle so genickt und erstmal stehend Ovationen gegeben, glaube ich. Mega die Idee einfach. Wie heissen noch mal diese Folgen, wo man alles sehr nah am Mikrofon macht und auch ab und zu mal ein bisschen einblicken lässt, wie es man in... Automatic Sensory Meridian Response, ASMR. Was auch mal ein bisschen so ein Einblick gibt, was in den Flüssigkeiten in deinem Körper passiert.
Ganz interessant, geht mit unserem Mikrofon aber nicht, die wir für 12 Euro beim Lidl gekauft haben.
Und eine 4 Euro Socke drüber gestülpt haben. Ja, eben. Das ist, glaube ich, wirklich ein Problem bei dir.
Warum? Die Socke?
Ja, hört euch nochmal die Folge, ab Folge 12 oder so an. Da hat Flo und den irgendwann angefangen, so eine Socke drüber zu stülpen über sein Mikrofon, was er für teuer Geld gekauft hat. Das, glaube ich, macht einfach katastrophalen Sound schlecht. Warum? Das ist Verhütung, das muss sein, ansonsten wäre es einfach zu krass. Ansonsten wäre es zu dreckig. Florentin sagt immer, wir ficken, ficken Penis, aber seine Socke ist ein Spamfilter und rauskommt dann irgendwie Neo, Neo, kommen diese Knaller-Gags. Apropos Knaller-Gags. Wir fangen heute wieder mit dem Hörspiel an, oder? Ich finde ja auch... Der Erfinder des Billigregals ist gestorben. Oder wie Peter Steinmeier sagen würde... Schade. Frühstück. Das finde ich auch immer so gut. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, wenn du Gags für die Sendung einreichst, für die wir beide schreiben. Du meinst, wie am Kraus ist eine neue Late Night Show. Ich denke immer an diesen Schubladen, diesen typischen Late Night Schubladen oder wie Saarländer sagen würden, Scheisse. oder genau dieser typische Frühstück-Gag, den man irgendwie immer macht. Ich hätte den immer in meinem Kopf und denke mir, bei jedem Thema denke ich mir zuerst an diese Feedline. Ja, vor allem das Problem ist, solche Gags schaffen es ja auch manchmal in die Sendung. Das ist das Problem. Also ich glaube, wenn man nicht so ein Gag lese, denke ich mir, ach Gott, immer so. Oder wie Saarländer sagen, Grossmutter. Oder halt so ein Schwachsinn immer. Die ganze Zeit kannst du einfach make your own Gag einfach. Da kannst du einfach auswürfeln, was dann einfach das Wort ist. Kannst du einfach sagen, oder wie Peter Altmaier sagen würde und dann guckst du in Duden, hast du irgendwo. Ja, aber das ist ein Problem, weil du denkst ja auch, ich hasse die selber, diese Witze, aber du machst sie ja selber, weil das ist das erste, was dir einfällt. Und ich glaube auch, dass es manchmal wichtig ist, das erste, was dir einfällt, einfach aufs Papier zu bringen, damit Nachschub kommen kann. Weil stell dir mal das Gehirn vor wie so eine Fabrik, du musst ja erstmal hinten was rausbekommen, damit mehr nachkommen kann. Du meinst ja der ganze Bodensatz, alles was in den Rohren hängt, so die Rohre müssen erstmal durchgespült werden. Deswegen ist es bei unserem Podcast, sind ja auch immer die ersten zehn Minuten immer scheiße, weil wir erstmal den ganzen alten, den verkalkten Dreck, der sich angesetzt hat über die Woche. Aber die anderen zehn Minuten sind auch scheiße, woran kann das liegen? Ja, vielleicht weil es einfach nicht so gut funktioniert. Aber heute funktioniert es super gut. Prost! Also wir stossen erstmal an. Hallo Stefan, mein Name ist Florian Will und wir begrüßen natürlich recht herzlich zu einer fantastischen neuen Folge, das Podcast UFO. Wir sind zurückgekehrt in einen alten Ort, ein fast jugendlich konnotierter Raum, in dem wir unsere Podcast-Pubertät erlebt haben. Das fangen gerade alle sehr schlau, war aber einfach nur Bullshit. Jagt zwar durch ein Google-Fremdwort-Translate. Und dann ergibt es Sinn, wenn man das ins Albanische übersetzt und ins Chinesische, dann nochmal zurück. War das ein gerader Satz? War ein gerader Satz und ich habe auch Chinesisch gesagt, statt Chinesisch sage ich jetzt auch mal, ich bessere mich, ich bessere mich, Stefan, ich nehme die Kritik auch ernstlich von der Community-Com, von wegen, äh, nicht lustig, viel zu selten, rummelt das Handy im Hintergrund und der Florentin sagt immer Kimi statt Kimi. Ich nicht mehr. Also wir sind in einem Raum, wo wir die erste Folge aufgenommen haben, zwischendurch eine Horrorfolge 12 und dann mal ein paar gute Folgen, glaube jeder. Luke Mockridge war auch hier, fand ich ja persönlich ein Highlight. Das war schön. Eigentlich, der hat jetzt auch wieder eine neue Sendung gestartet mit dem Musical-Opener, wo wir ihn, glaube ich, auch damals ein bisschen zu ermutigt haben. Waren es nicht meine Worte zu ihm, mach doch mal einen Musical-Opener. Ich weiß nicht, ob du allzu viel Verantwortung für diese Sendung haben willst tatsächlich. Nee. Na ja, ach komm. Aber da hatten wir heute wieder die Diskussion, ob schöne Menschen lustig sein können. Und das ist ja natürlich auch so ein bisschen, ist es wirklich so oder kommt es aus dieser hässlichen Blase, dass auch nur hässliche Leute kommen, die überhaupt konsumieren und sich mit hässlichen Leuten identifizieren können.
Ja, da war die Frage schon vorbei. Ich wollte gerne vorher, bevor wir kurz diese Frage klären, die sehr interessant finde, danke für diesen tollen Einstieg, würde ich gerne folgendes für die Folge abmachen. Lass uns jetzt mal beide unsere MacBooks auf lautlos stellen, so dass kein Mailgeräusch ankommt. Sehr gut.
Seit ein paar Folgen wünsche ich mir einfach, dass wir kein Mailgeräusch im Hintergrund haben, weil das wahnsinnig nervt.
Auch beim Schneiden denke ich mir immer so an ganz unangenehme Menschen. Ja, vor allem glaubst du, also ich finde zum Beispiel, dass wenn man heutzutage Chart-Songs schreibt, in denen irgendwelche Geräusche sind, die ähnlich sind wie Geräusche, wie zum Beispiel WhatsApp-Nachrichten oder so, da muss man doch einfach auch das Bewusstsein haben, dass es die Leute extrem abfragen wird. Ja, ich habe zum Beispiel ein Lied von den Libertines, eine Band aus... Libertines, glaube ich, heißt die. Ach komm schon, du mit deinem Scheiß... Er ist ein bisschen Libertines. Und da gibt es einen Song, der endet mit so einem Autogeräusch und... Und ich stand, während das Lied vorbei war, hier an der Fenlohrstrasse in Köln, an der Kreuzung und hatte mega Panik plötzlich, aber habe mich so umgeguckt, woher kommt dieses Geräusch und ich dachte, Wahnsinn, die Ampel sprang gerade auf grün oder so und dann kam dieses Geräusch und da habe ich mich panisch. Reiss dich auf dem Boden, gehst in Deck und reiss die Frauen neben dir noch zum Boden. Ich bin über die Ampel gerannt, weil ich an Angst hatte, dass da so ein Auto über Rot fährt plötzlich.
In Panik.
Vor allem, das ist doch auch irgendwie, mittlerweile läuft man ja auch mit diesen Geräuschen auf dem Ohr halt durch die Strassen, sollte man da nicht irgendwie so mal so eine Instanz ins Leben rufen, die das kontrolliert, dass man da vielleicht nicht jedes Geräusch irgendwie auf Platten stampft? Ich frage mich bei so vielen Sachen eigentlich, warum da niemand mal was dagegen macht, zum Beispiel auch bei so Songs, wo am Anfang erst mal zehn Sekunden gelabert wird oder sowas. Oder man dann erst mal so, bevor das Lied einsetzt, einfach 20 Sekunden lang so Ausschnitt hat, wo nicht mal jemand im Turnstuhl sagt, ja Leute, mach das so einfach raus, weil das geht den Leuten tierisch auf die Nerven, wenn man das Lied mehr als einmal hört. Oder Olli Schulz zum Beispiel beim Album. Cool, aber dann hast du auch so Texteile drin, die beim ersten Mal hören vielleicht witzig sind, beim zweiten Mal auch, beim dritten Mal naja, aber beim vierten Mal denkst du dann einfach, ja gut, soll ich jetzt mir nochmal extra eine neue Playlist anlegen, wo ich alle Songs reinnehme, ausser die oder die Olli Schulz Playlist haben, weil ich kann das Album als solches nicht konsumieren, weil ich immer wieder die Beatles sehe und denkst du, Alter, jetzt heil die Fresse, Mensch. Bestes Beispiel, Black or White, Michael Jackson, fängt genau ab einer Minute an, zum Lied zu werden.
Davor ist halt dieses Kind, was fälschlicherweise irgendwie die Musik zu laut auf dem Dachboden hört, und dann hört man dieses Hörspiel dazwischendurch, wo der Vater halt sauer ist auf das Kind und so, eskaliert völlig, und dann beginnt das Lied halt irgendwann. Und das sind genau eine Minute, das habe ich mir gemerkt, damit ich halt immer reinskippen kann, wenn das Lied kommt. Aber du musst doch auch alle gesagt haben, hey Michael, pass mal auf, das ist mega scheiße. Das ist eine scheisse Idee. Aber Michael hat gesagt, nein, Leute, ich will das so haben. Ja, und ist das gut oder schlecht? Ja, es ist... Die Beatles haben mal wirklich in einem Song, ist das Day in the Life oder so? Wenn du Anekdoten, die du anfängst, erzählst und beendest, kannst du nicht auf Hilfe von mir hoffen. Ich dachte, du hast schon ungefähr eine Ahnung, in welche Richtung ich gehen will. Nee. Jedenfalls gibt es da drin einen Part, der irgendwie so eine Minute lang nur Krach hat. Das machen die halt, damit es nicht im Radio gespielt wurde, das Lied. Ach, das ist natürlich eine geile Idee. Um sich halt so gegen das Establishment aufzulehnen. Coole Idee, aber hat Michael Jackson glaube ich nicht damit gemacht. Das wird trotzdem gespielt, weil die halt rein skippen direkt. Ach so. Ich glaube, ich habe das Lied wesentlich seltener gehört, als ich eigentlich wollte, nur weil der Anfang mich genervt hat. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Wir waren bei der Frage, die du gestellt hast eingangs, ob lustige Menschen hässlich sein können, schön sein können.
Das ist natürlich die Frage, also ich habe mich auch die Frage gestellt, welche Leute konsumieren überhaupt Comedy oder schauen halt Fernsehen, Late Nights, so Comedy-Sachen an. Und ist nicht das eigentlich eher ein Klientelproblem, dass die Leute, die erfolgreich sind und Frauen abkriegen, halt einfach mit etwaigen Frauen einfach durch die Häuser ziehen oder was man mit Frauen so macht, die halt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Blumen kauft oder was auch immer und halt nicht Comedy konsumieren und dann eher sich die Zuschauer mit den hässlichen Outsidern identifizieren können, weil Fernsehen und Comedy an sich ein Outsider-Medium ist. Glaube ich nicht. Also wir sind darauf gekommen, durch Enissa Arman und Luke Mockridge, die beide wahnsinnig gut aussehen. Ja, diese Woche sind ja drei neue Late-Night-Shows gestartet. Und beide, wie wir finden und nicht so lustig sind. Und ähm, geh mal bitte raus, David Wiesing, ey. Jetzt kann... David... Nehmen wir einen Podcast auf, du nieser Wieser. Dann komm auch rein. Dann komm auch rein. Du siehst genau, das ist eine Glastür. Du siehst genau, dass wir einen Podcast aufnehmen. Dich hatten wir schon... Dich hatten wir schon mal hier zu Gast. Komm mal her, du hast uns geraten, wie man aus der Friendzone kommt. Kannst du dich noch erinnern? Und seitdem will er selber einen Podcast machen. Und seitdem warst du nie wieder in der Friendzone, ne? Seitdem will ich einen Podcast über Friendzone machen. Schau mal, wir diskutieren gerade die Frage, ob schöne Menschen lustig sein können oder nicht. Ja, schau mich an. Also nein. Ja, jetzt in beide Richtungen beleidigend. Aber wir wissen nicht genau, in welcher. Entweder du bist hässlich, dafür lustig oder du bist wahnsinnig hübsch, aber nicht lustig. Wie hast du es wahrgenommen, das Kompliment oder die Beleidigung? Ich glaube, ich bin wahnsinnig hässlich, aber super lustig. Ja, ich hätte es anders verstanden. Also nicht, dass du schön bist. Ich mach mal gerade das Fenster auf, wenn du gerade da bist. Ich habe so ein bisschen lustige Witze zu haben gefallen, aber ich kann super schlechte Witze erzählen. Das ist der falsche Ort und die falsche Zeit, um Witze zu erzählen. Vor allem von dem, der die Kategorie Mitarbeiter des Monats Witz begraben hat, einfach weil er den Witze toll erzählt hat. Erzähl dir doch mal. Hä, was? Es gab doch mal diese Rubrik im Leo-Magazin, den Mitarbeiterwitz. Im Abspann. Achso, ja, und er hat ihn begraben, weil er den Gag so wahnsinnig lustig hat. Aber erzähl doch mal deinen Witz jetzt. Ich probiere mal, das hinzukriegen. Es ist wieder ein Arzt, der Patient sitzt bei seinem Arzt und der Arzt sagt, ja, ich habe eine sehr schlechte Nachricht für Sie, Sie haben Krebs. Und sagt der Patient, ja, also da hätte ich lieber noch mal eine zweite Meinung.
Und sagt der Arzt, ja, okay, und Sie sind hässlich.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Er ist nicht schlecht, er ist einer der besseren Arztwitzel.
Sehr gut, ciao!
Damit bin ich meine Damen und Herren!
Wuhuuu! Hast duaja, es ist ... Ein bisschen Stand-up-Club, der hier plötzlich entsteht. So ein uncooler Stand-up-Club. Es kommen immer mehr Leute rein, immer mehr Gäste. Nächstes Uhr alte Diskussion, die wir geführt haben, auch von wegen Outsider, muss man um Comedy um lustig zu sein, bla bla bla, anderer Blick auf die Welt. Nee, aber komm schon, ey. Ich hatte gerade so einen lustigen Ansatz, dachte ich mal eigentlich. Weil diese Woche sind drei neue Late Nights gestartet in Deutschland. Die sind alle in Umbruchzeit für die deutsche Comedy-Szene. Luke Mockridge, Anissa Armani und Aure Merz haben jeweils eine eigene Aurel-Show bekommen. Und sind alle gut aus. Und sowohl Anissa Armani als auch Aure Merz haben fantastische Quoten abgestaubt, nur Luke Mockert hängt hinterher. Echt jetzt? Ja, ein bisschen. Weil er bei uns war. Deswegen, sage ich mal, viele neue, frische Dinge sind über uns geschwappt diese Woche. Wie hast du das empfunden? Erstmal wollte ich nochmal auf die Eingangsfolge ausgehen, weil es ist doch weniger ein Problem. Ich glaube, es kommt eher aus der Ecke, man sieht gut aus, warum sollte man Comedy machen?
Also du hast selbstbewusst, du schleppst Frauen ab oder Männer und du hast einfach ein gutes Leben.
Also warum solltest du dich irgendwie in so eine Comedy-Ecke verlieren, wo du ja tendenziell, es kommt ja nicht alles gut an, was man als Comedian seit oder auch Privatcomedian labert.
Das ist ja die klassische Theorie und auf der Folgen könnte man zum Beispiel, wie es Christopher Hitchens getan hat, heute ist ja Weltfrauentag und deswegen können wir auch einfach heute mal sagen, Frauen sind nicht lustig, weil sie keine Frauen abschleppen müssen. Das ist natürlich die klassische Theorie, die ich jetzt so nicht hundertprozentig unterstützen möchte, aber die zum Beispiel vorgetragen wurde von Christopher Hitchens, der gesagt hat, Männer brauchen gewisse Balzverhalten, um Frauen flachzunehmen. Das ist der Bruder von Alfred Hitchcock. Und er meinte zum Beispiel auch, was ich ganz interessant finde, ist, dass tatsächlich das Lachen, also dieser gewisse Kontrollverlust, tatsächlich schon eine sexuelle Konnotation hat, dass wenn der Mann die Frau zum Lachen bringt, sie wirft ihren Kopf in den Nacken, sie öffnet den Mund weit, dass da schon eine gewisse Empfängnisbereitschaft zu politisieren. Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie kein Geräusch rauskommt, sie einfach den Mund aufmacht und den Nacken wirft. Auch gar kein Geräusch dabei erzeugt, einfach nicht lacht. Einfach sich anfängt auszuziehen, statt zu lachen. Wie wäre die Welt, wenn man nicht lachen würde, sondern sich eine andere Übersprungshandlung machen würde? Irgendwie dass alle plötzlich anfangen, ihre Finger zu knacken oder so. Oder zu tanzen oder so die ganze Zeit sich die Nase zu reiben, halt vor Nase immer reiben, statt zu lachen. Wie sähe die Welt aus, angenommen, dass Limousinen sind ja quasi so ein Symbol für Reichtum, ne? Das ist richtig. Limousinen. Angenommen, Limousinen werden sehr kurze Fahrzeuge, einfach, also in einem Universum ist es bestimmt so, dass Limousinen nicht überdurchschnittlich lange, sondern überdurchschnittlich kurze Fahrzeuge sind. Was für ein cooles Universum wäre das denn und wie wäre Reichstum überhaupt definiert? Oder einfach je reicher man ist, dass so ein kleineres Auto hat man. Und mein ganz armes hat man ein zwölf Meter langes Auto. Und alle sagen, oh Gott, er guckt diesen armen Schlucker an. Ja, dass man auch gar nicht so in Qualität geht, so Design, die sehen gut aus, sind schnell, sondern einfach nur in Länge. So ein konterintuitives Paralleluniversum. Ein gutes Brot ist einfach länger als ein schlechtes Brot. Oder umgekehrt, je besser es ist, desto kleiner ist es. Du hast ein bisschen selber voran in der Theorie. Ich habe mich gerade ein bisschen selber voran, das ist richtig. Aber was sagst du, also ich meine, die Diskussion ist natürlich nicht einfach und heute am Weltfrauentag natürlich auch ein bisschen kritisch. Hast du eigentlich so eine Topical-Richtung in die Geschichte? Ne, ich bin Topical Island, hast du nicht bekommen. Ich habe, während du, wenn du gerade auf dem Klo warst, habe ich Topical Island anmoderiert. Ach so, ein Jingle gestanden. Topical Island, Topical Island. Heute zum Weltfrauentag, unser Thema Untergang. Hunde. Hunde. Findest du, was ist das lustigste Tier? Colibri. Es kam sehr schnell, deswegen sollte ich es vielleicht begründen. Und dir dabei vielleicht nicht so lassiv über die Brust reiben, so als hättest du gerade, wie wenn man gut gegessen hat, reibt man sich über den Bauch und Stefan hat gerade einen guten Gag gemacht und reibt sich so ganz selbstverliebte in die Brust. Nee, ich finde Kolibri ist einfach wahnsinnig anziehend. Findest du eine andere Tierart eigentlich, also sexuell anziehen? Oh, das ist eine gute Frage. Eine Tierart. Also das ist genau wie wenn man ja als heterosexueller Mann sagen kann, man findet den Mann attraktiv. Ja genau, ein Tier. Könnte man ja auch als nicht zu vieler Mensch sagen, ich finde diesen Neger anziehend. Ich finde diese Leiche anziehender als eine andere Leiche. Welches Tier finde ich sexuell am Anziehen? Das ist echt eine gute Frage eigentlich. Ich glaube, ich würde tatsächlich in die Schlangenrichtung gehen. Ehrlich? Ich glaube, da kann man sexuell viel experimentieren. Ich glaube, da wird es interessant. Selma Hayek? Oder halt, also was, glaube ich, ein Klassiker ist, ist auch tatsächlich der Oktopus. Aus der asiatischen Literatur natürlich Hentai, ursprünglich von dem Traum der Fischersfrau, der grosse Oktopus. Wer war jetzt Hentai in diesem Moment? Wen hast du Hentai genannt? Mein Onkel Hentai. Der hast du auch mal getroffen. Opa Hentai, wie gut das wäre, wenn plötzlich einer von sich behauptet, weil es normal so viel in der Welt ist. Mein Opa, ich weiß nicht, College Porn Sluts. Einfach so ein Name, wo du gerade von Oktopus sprichst. Ich war am Wochenende auf einer Messe, wo ich ... Oh ja, da wollte ich dich anfragen, weil Stefan nämlich an, letzte Woche gesagt hat,
mein Wochenende wird so geil, weil ich gehe auf eine Messe und ich habe gesagt, ich prophezeie dir,
es wird mega lame, es wird mega scheisse, denn Messen sind immer scheiße.
Es war auch nicht mein Wording, dass es mega geil wird.
Naja, aber du hast dich schon darauf gefreut.
Ich habe gesagt, es wird vielleicht ein bisschen lustig.
Ich musste meine Uni repräsentieren, weil ich da irgendwie so Stunden absolvieren muss, weil ich ein Stipendium habe.
Aha, aha.
Kurz, wenn man den anderen so einen sophisticated Blick mal auf mich werfen kann. Ich will die Akademie ein bisschen mehr machen. Nicht schlecht, Mozart. Und dann war ich dann auf der Messe und wir hatten halt so einen Unistand und musste sich Leuten von der Uni erzählen. Und dann so ein Nebenstand. Was hast du dann erzählt über die Uni? Ja, halt was man bei uns studieren kann und was nicht und so und was es für ein Konzept Uni ist und wie ich heisse und wie man das buchstabiert. Und deine Telefonnummer und dein Twitter-Account. Tinder-Account vor allem, ja, ICQ-Nummer. Und nebenan gab es halt einen Stand der Visual-Effects-Studenten waren halt da, also Super-Nerds. Und es war quasi eine mega spiesige Veranstaltung, Eltern sind mit den Kindern rumgelaufen, um halt für die Zukunft zu gucken. Und am Nebenstand waren halt diese Visual Effects Firma und die hatten einen Fernseher. Wir waren mega neidisch, dass die einen Fernseher hatten, weil es einfach Leute anzieht. Im Fernseher zieht immer Leute an. Und es war halt wie gesagt eine mega spiesige Veranstaltung, aber bei denen im Hintergrund lief halt das, was die die ganze Zeitiert haben, die Leute, die da am Stand standen. Live animiert haben. Nein, die nicht live animiert haben, sondern was sie in ihrem Studium animiert haben. Und dann war es halt, ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Projekt war, aber es war halt so eine nackte Oktopusfrau, die halt so ein halb Oktopus, halb Mensch war, so grazil, aber auch ganz eng bekleidet nur. und es war unfassbar, es war wirklich unangenehm. Und die ganzen Eltern haben halt ihre Kinder immer weggeschlimmt von diesem Stand, weil nicht alle Kinder sind da hingeströmt. So sind ja so Abiturienten gewesen. Aber was heißt Oktopusfrau? Wo sind denn die Tentakeln? Nee, die kamen so, ich weiß nicht, so auf Hals, Unterseite des Halses raus. Das war so ein ganz gruseliger Stall. Also da ist so den Kopf einer Frau und dann die Tentakeln vom Hals. Ja genau, also hinten die Haare waren quasi so Medusa-mässig, die Tentakeln einer Oktopusfrau. Man muss sich das vorstellen, dass vorne halt teilweise auch Dozenten standen, die mit ihren Schülern darüber über die Uni gesprochen haben, ja bei uns können sie studieren, das ist eine private Hochschule und sie können sieben Semester und in dem Hintergrund drehte sich halt diese Oktopusfrauen in so ein Horror-Szenario.
Das war echt lustig. Und mir ist was passiert, was mega unangenehm war. Wie gesagt, ich stehe ja die ganze Zeit da, habe gesagt, ja, sie stehen sieben Semester, können sie bei uns studieren. Und es gibt auch ein Auslandssemester und ein Praktikumssemester. Und unsere Hochschule hat halt so Cubes, so kleine. Was ist das für ein Cube? So kleine Würfel. So kleine Würfel zum Hinsetzen, weil man dachte, man kann die Leute auch mal in den Stand holen, dann kann man sie da hinsetzen. Was ich nicht wusste, die waren sehr, sehr weich, die sahen aber sehr hart aus. Also will ich mich, während ich mit so Leuten spreche, so zwei Eltern, ja und was haben die so für Erfahrungen gemacht, wie im Studiengang, will ich mich so cool draufknien, aber knick halt ein und fall halt vor denen auf die Fresse. Sehr gut. Und es ist mega ungewohnt, als erwachsener Mann hinzufallen. Das bist du nicht mehr gewohnt. Ich weiss gar nicht, was du tun sollst. Du kennst es nicht. Als Kind kriegt man hin, schlägt man hin, als Senior fällt man öfter mal hin, aber dazwischen ist eine Zeit, wo man nicht hinfallen darf. Das hast du ja auch schon mal irgendwann gesagt. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist genau wie deine Geschichte, wo du diese Kordel trittst. Ja, genau. Und ich bin da draufgestimmt und habe seitdem auch komplette Autorität verloren, auch von mir selber so ein bisschen. Die Leute sind einfach Kopfschulden nach vorne gelaufen, so. Auf diese Hochschule gehen wir nicht. Da wollen wir die studieren. Die Studierenden schlagen hin, vor allem. Oder dieses klassische Kompetente, wenn du mit jemandem im Mediamarkt redest oder so und wenn derjenige merkt, meine Kompetenz zieht nicht ganz, dann stellen die manchmal ihren Fuss so hoch auf irgendwas, sodass man das nie so anwinkelt. Genau, das wollte ich ja auch machen. Und so, du stellst den Fuss drauf und drückst ihn einfach ganz nach unten durch und stehst wieder normal da. Und die so, okay, das ist das schöne Geste eigentlich, das ist richtig schön. Ich wollte es ja machen, wollte mein Bein auf diesen Würfel lehnen, während da, ich dachte, ja, ich bin halt so, so eine Checkerhaltung hat man dann ja auch, ich weiß alles, aber die Hochschule stellen mir einfach irgendwelche Fragen und die nirgendwo falle ich einfach hin, weil es da Würfel nachgibt. Mega unangemündig. Das ist geil. Macht doch mal ein Video, wie das bei euch aussieht und schickt es uns an www.podcast-gäste-liste-geister-wahn-at-org.
Viel Spaß.
At-org, ja.
Geil. Ja, cool. Aber war es im Endeffekt scheisse, die Messe oder nicht?
Ja, natürlich. Messen sind immer scheisse. Ich war auch mal auf so einer Berufsorientierungsmesse noch während dem Abi-Jahrgang tatsächlich. Um zu gucken, was du studierst oder warum warst du da? Nee, einfach nur so, weil man dachte, man müsste das tun, man müsste sich jetzt mal um die Zukunft kümmern, was ja genauso unnichtsagend ist wie die Zukunft selbst. Das heißt, dieser Zeitraum in seinem Leben, wo man sich um die Zukunft kümmert, ist ja mehr oder weniger einfach nur so ... Wenn du mit dieser Halbung schon an diese Messe gegangen bist, dann hast du, glaube ich, schon ziemlich genau vor Augen, dass du Philosophie studieren willst, oder? Ja, im Grunde. Ich hatte schon die Schauffischsprüfung, eigentlich schon ... Mensch und Hegel, er hatte schon in der Hinterhand, in der Rückentasche die ganze Zeit. Rückentasche? Was? What? Florentin, wovon redest du wieder? Du bist zu crazy.
Sei mal ein bisschen weniger crazy gerade.
Ey, die Leute folgen, die Leute können dir gerade nicht folgen.
Du bist mal wieder zu wild und zu alberleutig.
Zu weird.
Du hast keine Aussage.
Du hast keine Haltung und der aktuelle Anlass fehlt.
Und es ist ja immer nur weird, weird, weird bei dir.
Und Florentin, und du hast die Suppe nicht aufgegessen,
du wirst es nie zu was schaffen.
Du wirst niemals eine Freundin haben. Du wirst niemals eine Freundin haben. Florentin. Auf jeden Fall waren wir dann. Ich weiss gar nicht, ob ich das erzählen soll. Weiss ich nicht, weil wir mussten halt, meine Freundin und ich, wir waren da und wir mussten lachen die ganze Vorführung lang und wir durften nicht lachen und das war mega lustig, aber das übersetzt sich doch nicht. Jetzt muss ich das doch nicht vorstellen. Mein Gott, das Medium Podcast hat halt einfach seine Grenzen. Mein Gott, ich kann euch jetzt auch sagen, hier. Wenn wir mal eine Videofolge machen sollen, dann macht jetzt das Wasser an und dann rufen wir das Wasserwerk an, um zu prüfen, wie viel Wasserverbrauch gestiegen ist, das glaubt uns doch kein Mensch, oder? Ja, können wir mal kurz erklären. Wir haben uns eine alte Fernsehsendung angeguckt, eine Fernsehshow. Wünsch dir was aus den 70ern. Die hieß Wünsch dir was aus dem Jahre 72 oder sowas. Und die haben halt Familien gehabt, für die man im Endeffekt abstimmen musste, welche Familie einem am besten gefiel, welche am besten abgeliefert hat, in den geilen Kategorien, die die hatten. Man konnte halt abstimmen zwischen zwei Familien, indem man entweder den Strom angemacht hat oder das Wasser hat laufen lassen, also die Klospülung betätigt hat. Du hattest zwei Familien und die Zuschauer mussten entscheiden, wer gewinnt, aber anscheinend gab es damals noch nicht die Technologie, dass man irgendwie anruft oder irgendwie eine Postgeschreitze. Oder die Garten, die wollten einfach nur einen geilen Gag machen. So, und dann haben sie immer gesagt, okay, jetzt, wenn Sie für Familie A sind, machen sie bitte alle Lichtquellen in ihrem Haus an und dann haben sie den Live-Schalter zu dem Leiter der Stadtwerke oder was auch immer und dann haben sie, um wie viel Kilowatt ist jetzt gerade der Verbrauch gestiegen, um 100 Megawatt, oder Gigawatt, machen sie auch immer, und dann machen sie bitte wieder alles aus. Um 10 MB, das kann nicht sein, können sie es kosten. Gigabyte? Ey, das ist doch nicht mal halbe Super Mario Brothers. Sie sind in der Zeit ein bisschen verrutscht. Ach so, okay. Auf jeden Fall, dann musste man alle Lichter wieder ausmachen und dann hat sie gesagt, so, und wer jetzt für Familie B ist, der macht jetzt bitte alle Lichter nochmal an. Und dann, oh, es sind 50 Megawatt, wir haben kaum noch Strom, wir müssen den Reaktor zwei anschmeissen, los, schmeiß den Reaktor an. Oh nein, Kernschmelze, what, 15 Millionen sind jetzt gestorben, nein. Und gewonnen hat Familie Darius. Ich glaube, wenn man das heute machen würde, ist es ungefähr genauso schlimm, wie wenn man Ausländer tötet oder so. Ich glaube schon. Töten sie zwei Ausländer, wenn sie für Familie A sind. Und dann haben sie auch ein anderes System mit Wasser verbraucht, dass dann alle die Klospülung betätigen sollten, die alle die Haushalte, die für Familie A oder B gestimmt haben. Und dann haben sie bei den Wasserwerken angerufen. Also das ist ja brillant erst mal, aber auf der anderen Seite auch wirklich, also ich finde es einfach supergeil einfach. Irgendwann haben die das System dann geändert, wo die Autos sich finden, wie da der Sprung entstanden ist. Irgendwann war das System dann, man muss das Licht ausmachen, wenn man für Familie A oder B muss nur den Strom ausmachen. Also auch den Fernseher ausmachen. Ja, wahrscheinlich gab es auch damals schon Beschwerden.
Ich habe eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden. Wir verheizen hier gefrostete Dinosaurier den ganzen Tag. Was ist das für eine Sendung? Das muss die beste Redaktion der Welt gewesen sein, weil es gab eine Disziplin war, die haben Familien, mussten immer bestimmte Aufgaben bewältigen und verschiedene Punkte gegen andere Familien machen. Und eine Disziplin war halt, die haben Autos genommen, die Familie reingesetzt, dann einen Kran genommen, das Auto hochgehoben und in ein Wasser versenkt. Das Auto versenkt und die Aufgabe war, dass die Familien nicht sterben dürfen. Das war es im Grunde, nicht ertrinken war die Aufgabe. Die mussten sich halt dann befreien, die mussten die Tür aufbekommen und dann möglichst schnell aus dem Auto fliehen. Irgendwie, die haben das so verpackt, als wäre dann so, ja, so irgendwie so eine educational lesson, dass man sagt, ja, die müssen, damit die Leute zu Hause lernen, wie man aus Autos kommt, als ob es so eine Situation wäre, die anderen vorkommt. Wir zeigen ihnen, wie sie aus dem Wasser, aus dem Auto kommen, was im Wasser versenkt wurde. Ja. So, in welchem Land ist das ein Problem? Ja, vor allem ist es halt mega unrealistisch, weil das Auto wurde erst abgesenkt, bis es sich komplett in Wasser gefüllt hat und dann durften die erst anfangen versuchen rauszukommen, also wie es im echten Leben nie vorkommen wird. Die durften sich erst befreien, als sie aktiv ihr Leben bedroht war eigentlich. Ja, das ist einfach und vor allem auch bei, glaube ich, allen Familien, die wir gesehen haben, kamen sofort Sicherheitstaucher, haben die Tür aufgerissen, die Leute rausgerissen. Das heißt, kaum eine Familie hat es aus eigener Kraft überhaupt geschafft.
Es war vor allem eine Megapanik unter Wasser, immer, bei jeder Familie.
Aber dann, sobald die aufgetaucht sind, waren alle herzlich am Lachen und der Moderator war am Scherzen.
Und dann ist eine Mutter halt, eine Mutter auch noch, mega tragisch, hat sich nicht befreien können, weil die Tür nicht aufging, die Tür hat geklemmt.
Und der Taucher hat sie auch nicht aufbekommen.
Und es war wirklich aktiv das Leben bedroht. Und dann ist sie irgendwann hochgetaucht, und heutzutage würde die Sendung unterbrochen werden, aber der Moderator hat einfach nur gesagt, oh, Frau Meier hat Wasser geschluckt. Ja, wie ging es ihm? Und sie, ja, ich hatte schon ein bisschen Angst um mein Leben, und er ist ertrunken, aber naja, ist ja gut, wir haben es geschafft. Die Hauptsache ist, sie haben den Punkt. Unglaublich, ne? Also dieses, ach Scheiss drauf, weißt du, das war einfach eine andere. Es gibt so eine Skandalsendung einfach, die brechen mit allen Regeln. Wo sind diese Sendungen heutzutage hin, die über die Stränge schlagen? Das ist halt so, wie wenn du das erste Kind bist, weißt du, da gibt es halt einfach keine Regeln, da gibt es kein, du hast keine Erfahrung, du darfst alles machen. Wenn du das dritte Kind bist, gibt es keine Regeln. Eigentlich schon, habe ich auch gerade gemerkt, aber es ist jetzt, lach mal, man, scheiß da mal drauf, es ist tatsächlich einfach so ein, man hat einfach keinen Rahmen. Ja. Deswegen sind Hochzeiten auch so teuer, weil du den Leuten alles verkaufen kannst, die Preise beliebig hoch ansetzen kannst, weil die Leute keinen Vergleichswert haben. Die wissen einfach nicht, was eine Hochzeit kostet, deswegen kannst du die Orte und die ganzen Locations einfach für einen doppelten Preis verkaufen, weil die Leute einfach keinen Rahmen, weil sie nur einmal denken, sie würden nur einmal im Leben haben. Deswegen, das Podcast-Ufo-Tipp, heiratet öfter. Ja, genau. Heiratet einfach öfter. Oder informiert euch einfach bis zum Vor. Dann habt ihr am Ende ungefähr durchschnittlich das bezahlt, was man für eine Hochzeit zahlen soll. Die Das-Podcast-Ufo-Hotline können wir eigentlich auch aufhören. Hochzeitshotline. Falls ihr gerade eure Hochzeit plant, ruft an, wir geben eine Handynummer raus, dass ihr das nächste Mal live anrufen könnt. Und wir beraten euch zum Thema Hochzeit. Hast du dir schon mal, jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, ist es vielleicht nicht die männlichste Sache, die man machen kann, aber hast du dir schon mal auch nur eine Minute lang Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie deine Hochzeit aussehen könnte? Also hattest du schon mal so einen Gedanken wie, ach die Servietten könnten schon blau sein oder irgendwie einfach nur so ein Detail? Hattest du schon mal irgendeinen Gedanken dieser Art? Man muss dazu sagen, ich hätte schon sehr viele Phasen in meinem Leben, wo ich Dinge durchgedacht habe bis zum Ende. Die Halstuchphase, wir erinnern uns. Genau. Die Kopftuchphase. Meine Glatzephase, meine Nostarchephase, meine... Die Oben-Ohne-Phase. Ich trage sehr viele Luftballons an meinem Körperphase. Wie viele Nippelpiercings hattest du in deiner Hochzeit? Vierzehn. Vierzehn. Uai, uai, uai, uai. Aber nur an einem. Ich musste mir neue Nippel quasi dran implantieren lassen.
Es gibt doch so Ketten, dass man die beiden Nippel verbindet, oder? Damit man so eine Verbindung hat oder was genau. Ja, einfach damit man nicht so ziehen kann. Damit die beiden Nippel, die ja in der Geburt, im Embryo, gehören ja zusammen. Es ist ein grosser Nippel und dann faltet man sich ja so auf, wie so eine Origami-Schwan und dann ist man ein Mensch. Es gibt übrigens so Hals-Armbänder, wo Magnete dran sind, sodass man irgendwie besser... Um die Vollidioten aussortieren zu können direkt. Erstmal, damit das Eisen des Blutes quasi dahin kommt und dann hat man eine bessere Schwingung. Ich weiss nicht genau, wann man eine schlechte Schwingung hat in seinem Körper. Keine Ahnung. Ich habe mir, glaube ich, noch nie wirklich Gedanken über die Hochzeit gemacht, aber ich habe mich schon oft gefragt, wie man die Platzkarten schreibt. Ob ich einen Füller nehme oder mein Kalligrafieset. Ach so, ich dachte jetzt, welche Leute das zusammensetzt. Ob ich so Steintafeln mache. Wen ich einlade, ist ein großes Problem. Machst du eine Comedy-Hochzeit eigentlich? Ja. Bad taste, oder? Oder was machst du? Oder Vampir? Ich glaube, bei mir wird es Comedy-mässiger, wenn es Goodtaste in meinen Augen eine Goodtaste-Hochzeit ist. Weil ich glaube, in meinen Augen wäre es Goodtaste, wenn alle anderen sagen würden, es wäre eine Badtaste-Hochzeit. Zieht euch so an, wie ich mich anziehen würde. So ein bisschen direkt. Dann kommen alle auf so Pedalos angefahren und so. Eine unangenehme Hochzeit. Wie geht's eigentlich deinem, wollte ich jetzt immer ein bisschen, der Frühling kommt raus, wie geht's deinem Hoverboard? Hast du mich auch schon gefragt vor. Ja, ich weiß, ich will einfach, ich will einfach auf dem Laufenden. Es hat noch die Regel jeden Tag, wir leben in Köln, hier regt es jeden Tag. Und ich suche nach Ausreden, ich suche nach Ausreden, damit ich es nicht benutzen kann, aber nächste Woche, glaube ich, wird es sehr trocken. Schau mal, der Frühling kommt, der Sommer steht vor der Tür und ich würde gerne mal so ein bisschen so eine Abendatmosphäre machen. Eine Fensterfolge. Man sitzt an der Terrasse abends draußen und wir haben hier so ein grosses Fenster direkt. Ja, danke. Schau dir das mal an, hallo. Guck mal, ich glaube, man kann es auch ein bisschen hören. Och, das ist gleich eine ganz andere Atmosphäre. Guck mal, wie man kann den Himmel sehen. Alles ist da, so eine richtig schöne Abendatmosphäre. Freust du dich wieder auf den Frühling? Mal draussen sitzen mit den Freunden so ein bisschen. Ja, also ich sehe jetzt nicht so viel, weil das Fenster hat, mein Sicht wird komplett verdeckt jetzt. Du hast jetzt einen schönen Blick aus dem Fenster. So saß ich tatsächlich in der Schule immer, in meiner letzten Reihe und ich konnte das Fenster öffnen, sodass die Scheibe vor mir war, dass ich immer durch die Scheibe den Lehrer noch gesehen habe. Und auch immer reden konnte über den Lehrer, der sich gehört hat, der immer so lautlos gehört hat, wie du den Mund bewegt. Genau, das war meine größte Beschäftigung während der Schulzeit,
dass ich die Reflektionen in der Scheibe dann immer so bewegt habe,
dass sie so die Köpfe von den anderen Schülern abschlagen.
Wenn sich draußen irgendwie nur Laternenpfosten reflektiert,
dann habe ich ja die Reflektion, wenn das Fenster vor mir ist.
Dann habe ich das Fenster immer so ruckartig bewegt und habe mir vorgestellt, wie dieser Laternenpfosten den anderen Schüler den Kopf abreißt. Nicht schlecht. Es sah gerade so aus, als ob du am Fenster rauchen wolltest. Das Fenster ist so aufgemacht. Ich war mal auf einer Musikfreizeit, wir hatten in unserer Schule immer so Musikfahrten, wo wir dann auf so eine Musikakademie gefahren sind. Und da durfte man halt auf dem Zimmer nicht trinken und nicht rauchen, und ein Bandkollege damals von mir hat am Fenster geraucht, aber einfach weil er es aus Filmen gesehen hat, er sollte am Fenster rauchen, weil es war einfach mega ineffektiv, weil die ganze Zeit einfach der Wind von draussen reinkam und den Rauch im Zimmer verteilt hat. Und Raub und Schnee. Optimal und Kinderfunk rein, es ist alles einfach so, alles rein, und dann kam halt rein, oh, er hat doch jemand geraucht und alle so, nein, nein, aber es war alles nebelig und der Wind hat alles so reingeblasen. Das sind auch so Dinge, die man aus Filmen kennt, so dass man am Fenster raucht, aber es macht einfach keinen Sinn. Ja, ausser das Haus steht in Flammen, glaube ich, dann hast du eine gute Chance wegzukommen mit Rauchen, aber ansonsten, glaube ich, ist es eher schwierig. Ich habe als Kind mal einen Stroheim geraucht, einen Pl Plastikstrohalm. Ich glaube, das ist ganz, ganz schlecht, glaube ich. Das ist das Schlechteste, was man rauchen kann, Plastikstrohalm. Das war dann auch so, okay, gut, ich rauche nie wieder. Das war eine gute Lektion, glaube ich. Ich habe Gras gegessen mal, weil ich mir dachte, Kühe essen Gras, Pferde essen Gras, viele, 50 % aller Tiere. Meine Vorbilder, meine grössten Vorbilder essen Gras. 50 % aller Tiere, die ich kenne, essen Gras, weil man kennt ja noch nicht so viele Dinge auf der Welt. Ja, das stimmt. Und man kennt eigentlich Schweine, eigentlich alle Tiere, die man so als Kind kennt, reissen Gras. Und man selber definiert sich ja auch nicht wirklich als Mensch. Doch nur Pferde und Kühe. Ja, aber mehr kennt man doch nicht als Kind vielleicht dann auch. Und dann habe ich mich einfach auf die Wiese gekniet und habe dann angefangen, Gras zu essen. Das ist so uncool. Naja, nee, aber... Dass du einfach jetzt aufs Handy guckst. Ja, Entschuldigung, es ist gerade wichtig, weil einfach parallel ein paar Dinge laufen. Was läuft denn, was so wichtig ist? Mein Gott, er schickt mir Fotos. Warte, das Foto muss ich dir auch zeigen. Das ist ein lustiges Foto. Wer schickt dir Fotos? Hannes. Kann Hannes mal aufhören, ihm andauernd Fotos zu schicken? Mein Gott, der Typ ist so ein Trottel, ey, ohne Witz, Entschuldigung an der Stelle, wenn du es hörst, Hannes, ich habe ihm geschrieben, schickt mir bitte alle Fotos und jetzt schickt ihr mir ein großes Foto, wo alle 20 Fotos so nebeneinander sind, so eine grosse Kachel, so ein Fotos, wo alle Fotos nebeneinander sind, also ein Trottel, Entschuldigung, es ist übersetzt sich jetzt gerade nicht.
Wenn auch ihr live im Podcast beleidigt werden wollt.
Ja, schickt mir Nachrichten. Schickt uns einfach Fotos. Was steht denn eigentlich unter unserem Tweet? Wir können ja mal ganz kurz gucken, was die Leute so... Wir haben vor der Sendung einen Tweet abgesetzt, weil wir im Lidl eingekauft haben. Sollte man dazu sagen, wir haben ein bisschen die Regeln gebrochen. Wir haben quasi das Kassentrenn-Segment vertikal auf die Kasse gelegt. Krippi fragt, habt ihr den Sponsor gewechselt? Wo ist Booster Energy? Oh, die Herren leisten sich Getränke bei Edeka. Ist falsch, kein Edeka. Ihr seid so wilde Hyänen. Ja, vielen Dank. Wie ist das ausgegangen? Verstehe ich nicht. Bekommt ihr dann wieder Aufruf? Ja, richtig tolle Community. Vielen Dank für euer Input, für euer Feedback. Immer gerne gesehen. Fantastisch, einfach weiter so, schreibt weiter Kommentare. Ihr seid die Best besten. Ich wollte nur kurz dir eine Frage stellen, die ich lustig finde und wo ich noch keine Antwort drauf gefunden habe. Ich habe neulich im Internet, also auch gerade im Moment, wo wir immer noch im Thema Topical Island sind, also die Musik, die karebische Musik. Crystal Meth ist ja gerade ein großes Thema. Crystal Meth ist ein Trend. Und da habe ich das gegoogelt und ich habe ganz viele Bilder von Meth-Abhängigen bekommen.
Kriegt man immer so Vorher- und Nachher-Bilder von Meth-Abhängigen.
Ich habe mich gefragt, woher kommen die ganzen Vorher-Bilder von Meth-Abhängigen?
Weil es sind ja davor schon Mag-Shots meistens, also von der Polizei gemachte Fotos.
Es sind Shots, es sind einfach die gleichen Shots, wo Wurz und Teufel her wissen die,
was das aus ihrem schönen Gesicht dann irgendwann mal so Horror fratzen werden? Und warum ändern sie das nicht? Sollte, wenn man so einen Muckshot bekommt, irgendwie seinen Lifestyle ändern vielleicht? Also wenn man gerade so einen Muckshot macht, weil man halt wahrscheinlich Methodik sein wird. Also woher kommt das bitte? Das ist eine gute Frage, ja. Alle Methodiks haben halt diese Vorherbilder. Ich frage mich das zum Beispiel auch immer bei Schauspielern, die ja manchmal in Filmen Kinderfotos von sich selbst brauchen. Und dann irgendwie so, ich habe bei Whiplash oder so, ich habe früher schon immer viel Schlagzeug gespielt, das ist halt ein Kinderbild, wo er im Schlagzeug ist. Ist das eine Photoshop-Arbeit? Nee, ist auch nicht im Film tatsächlich, ist bei einer Pop-Show. Aber generell, Kinderfotos, die teilweise auch wirklich passende Szenen zeigen, klar kann natürlich jetzt momentan alles Photoshop gemacht werden, aber da auch so, wir brauchen einen Schauspieler, der ein Kinderfoto von sich hat, wie er mit einer Badehose neben dem Esel steht, weil das ein wichtiger Plotpop ist. Und am besten noch ein Academy Award Gewinner, aber okay. Ja genau, und da muss ein Academy schon in der Hand sind, aber irgendwie sowas brauchen wir. So ein wahnsinnig detaillierter Steckbrief, den nach dem gesucht wird dann auch. Ja genau, früge Kleinanzeigen. Wir haben einen gefunden. Aber vorher Fotos finde ich immer genial. Ich finde, es ist auch ein guter, guter, na wie sagt man, wenn man Leute beleidigt. Arschloch. Ne, ne, ne, wenn man halt so wie mit Comedy beleidigt. Blödmann. Ne, aber ich meine jetzt eher so Situationen, in denen berühmte, ne, ne, ne, du verstehst nicht, was ich meine. Ich meine die Situation, wenn berühmte, hör mir ganz kurz zu, berühmte Leute sich über andere berühmte Leute, nein, es geht um eine gewisse Art der Beleidigung. Birnen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht so etwas wie Rant, man, fuck, wie heißt das denn? Apfel, nein, mir fällt nur noch Obst ein, Obstbeleidigung. Hier, wo in Amerika die Leute, wo immer sich fünf Leute versablen, und dann,amo. Und dann, nein, und dann sich überein, äh, Burnen, nicht, fuck man, es heisst nicht Burnen.
Rent.
Nein, es ist eine Mischung aus Burn und Rent.
Brand, Burned, Brr, Brad Pitt, Barnt, Barney, Barney, Barney Gumbel, Bar, Burning Man.
Mann, ey, das kann nicht wahr sein, du weisst das Wort, oder?
Du willst mich... Renten. Haben wir uns eben auch gefragt. Roasten! Roasten! Die längste Einleitung ever. Für einen Okayen-Gang. Ja, für, wenn man jemanden roasten will, so ein Foto, du siehst aus wie ein Vorherbild. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Wow, dankeschön. Ja, mein Gott, alles ist scheiße, wenn man zu lange aufbaut, ey. Für die letzten 20 Minuten. Mein Gott, alles wird schlecht, wenn du es zu lange aufbaust. Ey, ich danke dir dafür, weil wir haben lustige Ob Hygiene und Ästhetik. Wie oft wäscht du dir deine Haare ungefähr? Ich würde sagen, so alle drei Tage, zwei, drei Tage vielleicht. Ich wasche mir sie jeden Tag. Das heisst, angenommen, ich habe jetzt irgendeinen wichtigen Punkt, wo ich zum Beispiel mit einer Frau Kuh mich treffe, abends, man geht zusammen weg, man hat sich irgendwie über eine App kennengelernt vielleicht. Ja, ich kann mir besser vorstellen, wenn du einfach von dir alleine sprichst, wie du in den Flicks guckst. So, ich bin zu Hause bei WoW mit einer Gilde und muss dafür gut aussehen. Dann muss ich immer bedenken, okay, ich muss mir zwei Tage davor die Haare waschen und dafür bis zu dem Zeitpunkt die Haare nicht waschen, damit es gut aussieht. Ja, aber das ist zum Beispiel genauso wie rasieren. Du darfst dich nie am D-Day, am Tag X, darfst du dich nicht rasieren. Du musst dich am Tag davor rasieren, weil sonst deine Haut so gerötet scheiße aussieht. Das habe ich am Easter als Teil des Mann Erwachsenwerdens, ist es ja ein großes Problem, rasieren. Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir war. Das sieht man dir sehr an tatsächlich, dass du da noch groß... Warum hast du schon dreimal in die Richtung heute geschlagen? Ich weiß nicht, warum genau das kommt. Stefan, wenn du in die Arbeit kommst und auf deinem Arbeitsplatz liegt eine Packung von sechs Einwegrasierern, so Rasierklingen, dann ist es ... Dann könnte das daran liegen, dass ich ein Rasierproblem habe oder dass ich dich geprankt habe und du Rasierer gekauft hast, mein lieber Freund. Weil ich Mr. Prankster es wieder geschafft habe. Vielleicht war es ein Doppelprank, dass ich dich geprankt habe, dass du nur dachtest, dass du prankst mich, aber eigentlich habe ich dich geprankt. Prank? Ich habe mich immer, weil man das auch irgendwann machen muss einfach, weil man zu dumm ist als pubertierender Junge, habe mich immer an dem Tag, an dem abends die Party auch war, habe ich mich abends noch rasiert. Die Party, also alles halbe Jahr mal. Und was das so führte, weil man halt auch nicht gut rasieren kann, weil das auch Übung erfordert, dass ich immer so Cuts hatte, so kleine Blut, einfach ... Auch an den Armen. Ich kann meistens immer blutüberströmt abends dann einfach auf Partys an, weil ich mich die rasieren konnte. Wegen Blutverlust direkt umgekippt und musste abgefahren werden, aber es waren coole Partys. So einfach hingefahren, umgekippt, wieder zurückgefahren. Was sind eigentlich unsere jüngsten Zuhörer? Glaubst du, wir haben wirklich junge Zuhörer, die jetzt wirklich zu Anfang Pubertät stehen, die jetzt gerade ihren Körper entdecken und Tipps brauchen? Also falls ihr Tipps braucht, Leute, wir sind glaube ich die Kompetentesten, was Körperhygiene, was vor allem die weiblichen Fortpflanzungsorgane angeht. Falls ihr da konkrete Fragen habt, was Hygiene angeht, wie, wo, was. Ist Intimbehaarung bei dir ein grosses Thema in deinem Leben gewesen? Ist ein sehr grosses Thema tatsächlich und ich habe mich da auch intensiv mit beschäftigt, das heißt, wenn ihr konkrete Fragen habt, auch männlich, weiblich, je nachdem wie ihr da aussieht untenrum, lasst uns einfach mal eure Fragen sammeln und dann machen wir nächste Folge mal einen schönen Rundumschlag, einfach mal die Hosen runter.
Nee, ich finde es wirklich interessant, weil da sind so ein paar Sachen, die sind einfach so unangenehm zu fragen.
Es sind einfach Probleme, über die man nicht gerne spricht.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Oberflächen des Hodensacks ja dermassen rau ist, aber irgendwann wurde gesagt, manche Leute haben das gehört, aufgeschnappt, die rasieren sich das und man sich dann immer selber fragt, wie, wie soll das gehen, aber man traut sich nicht zu fragen, weil es einfach so unangenehm ist. Irgendwann probiert man es einfach aus, fügt sich sehr, sehr grobe Wunden zu, ist impotent, einfach direkt und das war es dann tatsächlich. Um das zu vermeiden, ach Gott, was kommt jetzt denn, um das zu vermeiden, mein Gott, um das zu vermeiden,
weil da kommen wir, kommen wir ganz kurz rein, wir sind gerade beim Thema Intimrasur, kommen wir ganz kurz rein.
Ja, aber Intimbehaarung können wir kurz nochmal über sprechen.
Stefan hat gerade die Frage gestellt, wie man sich den Hoden am besten rasiert.
Die Heizung kriegen wir nicht richtig runtergestellt. Stefan hat gerade die Frage gestellt, wie man sich den Hoden am besten rasiert. Kannst du uns da einen Tipp geben an die jüngeren Zuhörer? Im Ernste jetzt, weil die Oberflächenstruktur ist nicht so gut dafür gemacht zum Rasieren. Siehste, das haben wir immer gesagt, das ist so unangenehm darüber zu sprechen, aber das ist ein großes Problem. Du bist 14 Jahre älter als wir und kannst trotzdem noch nicht offen mit das Thema Riemen. Aber es ist ein großes Problem, dass man darüber nicht sprechen kann. Es ist mir peinlich, ich habe das halt noch nie gemacht wahrscheinlich einfach.
Siehst du hier unten beim Knöchel kommen auch so Haare raus.
Er zeigt uns gerade seinen Penis tatsächlich.
Da kommen so Haare raus.
Aber unten bei der Hose kommen.
Ja, ich weiss auch nicht. Aber macht man das heutzutage?
Ich weiss es nicht, ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen, ob ich es gemacht habe oder nicht.
Aber wir müssen ja nicht sagen, ob du es gemacht hast, macht man das generell?
Na, ich glaube nicht so richtig. Ich glaube, man trmt sich das mit elektrischen Rasierern, glaube ich. Kann man sich dann schneiden mit dem elektrischen Rasier? Ja, glaube schon. Ich finde, das grösste Problem bei Intimrasur ist ja so ein bisschen das Kotelettenproblem. Dass man nicht genau weiss, wie weit man rasieren soll. Weil der Intimbereich ist jetzt kein abgetrennter Bereich, der geht ja über. In den Bauchraum und den Arschraum. In andere Bereiche. Generell ist dein Körper erstmal komplett behaart, vielleicht nicht stark, aber er ist zumindest sichtbar behaart. Und wenn du jetzt einen Teil des Körpers rasierst, dann sieht man das ja, weil die Haare irgendwo aufhören und wieder anfangen. Und die Frage ist, wo ist diese Linie? Weil du rasierst dann auch zum Teil in den Oberschenkel rein, aber wie weit? Weil du kannst ja, das ist ja... So ist das schon öfter gemacht. Aber ist das dann ein fliessender Übergang in den behaarten Oberschenkel rein? Du musst versuchen, wie so ein Farbverlauf. Ja, aber das ist nicht so einfach mit einem... Nee. Aber wo fängt der an und wo hört der auf? Das versuche ich auch an meinem Hals und dafür habe ich dann für meinen elektrischen Rassiteer verschiedene Stufen, die ich einstellen kann. Ah! So dass man sich mit Stufen vorarbeitet, aber das ist untenrum unmöglich. So Beauty Palace YouTuber, die auch... Ich weiß nicht, ob Dagi da man hier zugemacht hat, ehrlich gesagt. Nicht schlecht! Julienko, wenn du das hörst! Du bist gefragt an der Stelle, weil es muss ja auch symmetrisch sein, weil du kannst ja nicht auf einer Seite bis zu den Kniekehlen runterrasieren, so einstreifen und auf der anderen Seite nicht, das sieht ja auch wieder scheisse aus.
Oder einfach mal, wir haben ja zwei Beine, dass man einfach mal verschiedene Varianten anbietet.
Genauso, jetzt mal so einfach nur was sagst du, sieht natürlich aus. Problematisch sind natürlich auch die Stellen, die man nicht so gut sehen kann. Ich rede jetzt vom Rücken. Wie sieht es da aus?
Habe ich kein Problem, bin ich glaube ich zu jung.
Bin ich auch zu jung, habe auch keine Probleme.. Ach, bitte dich, du bist 80 Jahre alt. Okay, aber das macht meine Mutter. Okay. Dafür bin ich meine Damen und Herren. Dafür bin ich, vielen Dank, dass du da warst. Schönen guten Abend noch. Also das ist ein Problem. Schreibt immer in die Kommentare, wie ihr das mit der Intimrasur handhabt. Aber auch hier die Frage, warum gibt es keine männlichen YouTuber, die das angehen? Ich glaube, in der weiblichen Community ist das ein bisschen. Ich glaube, Sami Slimane hat gerade was Rasur und so angeht schon. Echt? Es ist state of the art, was die Rasurthemen angeht bei YouTube, glaubst du? Ich weiss es nicht tatsächlich, aber. Du hast schon wieder tatsächlich gesagt. das ist mir aufgefallen, weil Leute das beklagen. Wie oft glaubst du, sagt man ein Wort, bis es Leuten auffällt? Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, man müsste dann halt sich ... Weil mir ist es nicht aufgefallen, mir ist es aufgefallen, weil Leute gesagt haben, du sagst sie auf tatsächlich, seitdem fällt es mir auf und seitdem hasse ich dich noch und so mehr. Ja, aber glaubst du, das ist nicht so eine self-fulfilling prophecy, dass wenn du denkst, jemand sagt es häufig, dass du es dann auch häufiger hörst. Selektive Wahrnehmung. Ich glaube, du könntest jedes beliebige Wort sagen, dass du sagst, oh, Stefan sagt die ganze Zeit ausserdem. Und wenn du mit dem Bewusstsein dir Stefan anhörst, wirst du das häufiger hören und deswegen deine Vermutung bestätigen. Denn die Realität ist menschengemacht, subjektiv und jede Objektivität ist eine Illusion. Das klang so ein bisschen verschwörerisch gerade.
Verabschiedet euch davon. Danach kommt irgendwie so was, die Holocaust ist eine Lüge, das wäre jetzt so der gerade Fluss deiner Argumentation gewesen. War eine Notlüge. Sorry, Holocaust, war sorry. Ich musste mir irgendwas ausdenken, meine Frau hat mich gefragt, sag mal Adolfo, warst du gestern? Ich habe die Juden vergast, so, ah wirklich, und so ist das alles entstanden. Allzu Notlüge.
Also, der Erfinder des Bildregals ist gestorben. Er ist wohl zusammengebrochen einfach. Aber Gott sei Dank liegt, also man muss sich das Wort vorstellen, angenommen, Körperteile wurden abgetrennt, aber Gott sei Dank liegt eine Anleitung dabei, wie man das wieder zusammenbaut. Richtung Sarg, gehen wir in Richtung Sarg, in welchem Sarg wird er begraben, der Erfinder des Bildungsregals? Smörebröd, hat irgendeinen lustigen Namen, so einen Ikea-Namen. Er wird zu Köttböller verarbeitet. Oh, nicht schlecht, David begut. Er wird mit Preiselbeeren begraben. Es ist vielleicht ein bisschen, muss man ein bisschen um die Ecke denken. Aber bei Ikea, er hat nur vier Jahre lang gehalten oder so. Er hatte nur ein Alter von zwei Jahren oder sowas und ist dann kaputt gegangen. Man kann mit seinen Innereien im Small Land spielen, mit seinen Nieren irgendwie. Ja, aber wie heisst denn dieses, dieser Metallhaken, Imbus oder Nimbus? Imbus. Oder Limbus, ich weiss es immer einfach nicht. Imbo. Imbo, Igo, Imbo? Imbus. Imbus, ja. Worauf ist die hinaus? Keine Ahnung, so was wie seine... Was ist die private Frage? Wie heißt übrigens dieses Ding, mit dem man Dinge aufgemacht hat? Seiner Leiche lag ein Imbus bei oder so was, oder dem Sarg, den Sarg muss man selber aufbauen. So was in der Rechnung. Falls ihr die besten Gags hören wollt, dann schaltet am Donnerstag das Neumagazin Royale ein. Kennst du das, wenn du Dinge betrachtest und dir fällt auf, dass eine Sache gar nicht reinpasst? Ich werde konkreter. Ich habe Stronghold 2 gespielt. Geiles Spiel. Mega geiles Spiel. Das ist auch von der Grafik her, muss man sagen, wirklich gut. Es ist halt dieses Aufbauspiel, du kannst eine Burg bauen, greifst Gegner an und es ist halt wirklich, es versucht halt so mittelalterlich die Stadt irgendwie abzubilden, aber es ist halt sehr reduziert. Es gibt keine, es gibt halt nur Jägerstände fürs Essen und Obstplantagen und so, es ist halt sehr reduziert. Es reduziert die ganze Bandbreite des Mittelalters auf so ein paar Dinge. Aber es gibt ein Ding, eine Sache, die sehr spezifisch ist, was mir mega, es ist mir aufgefallen, ich war schockiert, weil du kannst Katapulte bauen, das ist auch eines der wenigen Dinge, die man halt sich rausgepickt hat, weil es repräsentativ ist und dann kannst du mit Katapulten angreifen und dann gibt es einen so einen Knopf, der mich ein bisschen irritiert hat, nämlich du kannst eine Kuh werfen. Du kannst, es ist alles mega reduziert, alles mega easy, es gibt nur Bogenschützen, Lanzen und berittene Bogenschützen und du kannst eine Kuh werfen. Aus heiterem Himmel. Wie abgefahren ist das denn? Weißt du, warum man das macht? Eine Kuh werfen? Ja, um Krankheiten in die Burg zu säen. Das ist so eine kranke Kuh, für Absatzweite so Krankheiten und dann wirfst du die Kuh in die Burg, was tatsächlich gar keine schlechte Idee ist. Aber in dem Spiel kannst du das ja nicht. Doch, dafür ist das da. Ich glaube, die Kuh ist auch automatisch krank, wenn du die abfeuerst. Das ist die Idee. Ich glaube, das wurde im Mittelalter tatsächlich auch so praktiziert, weil das keine dumme Idee ist. Aber es ist schon sehr speziell. Es ist sehr speziell und der Gang funktioniert trotzdem und ich glaube, die Leute haben herzlich gelacht. Trotzdem würde ich jetzt ganz gern nächsten... Kannst du jetzt noch mal vielleicht lachen, dass ich das Essen nach einbauen kann?
Geil, also Stefan, das ist immer... Ja, reicht, keine... Danke dir. Ne, das wollte ich nur mal anmerken, weil ich bin darüber gestolpert. Ja. Gedanklich. Stolperst du mal über Dinge eigentlich? Ist das wirklich so? Nein, nein, abgesehen. Nein. Ähm, falls du jetzt darauf eingehen willst, dass ich mein Gag-Dokument vorlesen soll, dann... Nee, will ich nicht. Ist tatsächlich das falsche Dokument. Ich kann nochmal ein One-Liner-Thema raushauen. Die Bundeswehr hat jetzt einen tödlichen Laser. Was kann sie damit machen, trifft sie auch nicht, genau wie G36 trifft daneben. Die Idee ist, dass man damit lautlos Ziele ausschalten kann, weil der Laser ja kein Geräusch macht. Was könnte man da für einen Gag draus machen? Das finde ich auch so lustig, dass man sich so lange auf Dinge freut, wie zum Beispiel auf so einen Leonardo DiCaprio, der einen Oscar gewinnt, dass es endlich einen Laser gibt, der Menschen töten kann. So ein paar Dinge, auf die man sich ja ein Leben lang freut und dann enttäuschen sie einen, wie Leonardo DiCaprio hält eine scheiß Rede beim Oscar oder der Laser macht einfach ein wahnsinnig uncooles Geräusch und genau so wie bei Elektroautos, wo ein riesen Vorteil ist, dass sie keine Geräusche machen,
man aber aus Sicherheitsgründen denen Geräusche geben muss und dann da einfach irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, einen Nokia-Klingelton den ganzen Tag laufen lässt, damit irgendwie blinde Leute
nicht einfach ausgerottet werden, weil sie einfach konstant überfahren werden.
Oder man die ganze Zeit in so einem coolen Tesla rumfährt und so eine Musik kommt. Mähmäh, mähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmähmäh und mal ein großes Rad zwischen den Füssen und fährt durch die Gegend, saust durch die Gegend, um nicht zu sagen. Das ist auch das Segway-Prinzip, also wenn du nicht nach vorne lest, dann versucht das Gerät das auszugleichen und schleunigt nach vorne und dann kannst du fahren. Da gibt es eine Version von, wo du eine Bluetooth-mässig eine Musik anschliessen kannst. Weil du noch nicht uncool genug bist, musst du da jetzt auch irgendwie Pitbull featuring Caccia Candela spielen. Es sieht mega uncool aus, wie du durch die Gegend rast damit und kannst dann noch irgendwie nebenbei Back in Black, Black or White. Back to Black, Back in Black.
Vier Titel vermischt einfach die Mesh-A-Version, Back in Black.
Back in Black ist ein Song, weil es easy.
Sorry, just saying.
Kann er was Uncooleres trinken als beim Lidl des Mineralwasser Medium?
Einfach danach.
Mit Saskia Namen, Namen Saskia.
Er trinkt Saskia. Er hat mir Jack überhaupt nicht gefallen und er nimmt einen Schluck Saskia. Apropos Oscar-Verleihung, ich frage mich immer, weil zum Beispiel der Oscar für den besten Tonschnitt, ja, interessiert keinen Schwanz, aber wird natürlich auch prämiert und der Typ geht auch auf die Bühne, kriegt den Oscar und geht runter. Ich frage mich, wird der in der Woche nach der Oscarverleihung auch angesprochen auf der Strasse? Also erkannt, du bist doch der Typ, der Oscar besten Tonschnitt gewonnen hat, oder so.
Ja, ja, tatsächlich, hier Selfie, Selfie, Selfie. Glaubst du, die haben auch sowas wie Ruhm ein
bisschen? Nein, weil es gibt nämlich diese gellige Statistik, dass man ja alle gesagt hat, wow,
die Capri wurde so oft nominiert und hat nie einen bekommen und mittlerweile haben auch Leute
erst einfach, es wurde so gehypt und Leute wollten, dass er das gewinnt. Aber irgendein dämlicher Tonmann war irgendwie 80 Mal nominiert und er hat nie einen Oscar bekommen. Ja, der Ennio Morricone zum Beispiel, der auch erst jetzt einen Oscar bekommen hat. Und das ist sogar noch eine relativ bekannte und beliebte Kategorie, Musik, Filmmusik. Er hat auch schon tausendmal nominiert. Aber glaubst du nicht, dass du der Oscar für bestes Drehbuch oder so, dass der auch mal angesprochen wird, also dass der erkannt wird? Was ist denn die letzte Kategorie, die noch erkannt wird auf der Straße? Ich glaube, Drehbuch ist da ungefähr dabei. Wobei, manchmal schreiben ja auch die Regisseure Drehbücher, dann kennt man die dann wahrscheinlich eher, aber so glaube ich, also Tonschnitt kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Genau wie diese eine Frau dabei war, die Costume-Design für Mad Max gemacht hat und einfach in so einer Lederjacke und so in einer Jeans hochlief und alle halt erstmal so an die Köpfe verdreht hat. Die verhaftet wurde, Security hat sie sofort zu Boden getackert. Genau, weil die dachten, es wäre einfach so eine, ich weiß nicht, Pussy Riot oder so, die das irgendwie stürmt oder so. Gegenteil von Pussy Riot, so eine alte Frau mit ganz viel Kleidung an, statt nackte junge Frauen. Die war halt so eine Femen-Frau, einfach was man nicht erwartet. Doggy Riot. Die war halt so ganz seltsam angezogen, hat so eine Liederjacke angehabt, hat so ein Peace-Zeichen hinten drauf und hat so eine Jeans halt angehabt. Und eine Jeans mit den Oscars sieht schon seltsam aus. Apropos Ruhm, du wurdest ja heute angesprochen und ein Selfie mit dir gemacht. Wie war das für dich? Ja, da brauchen wir so viel drüber reden. Doch, natürlich, ich würde gerne drüber reden. Weil die so ein Freak uns auf der Strasse anspricht. Nee, nicht uns, dich! Du wurdest heute heute angesprochen und ein Selfie mit dir gemacht. Wie war das für dich? Ja, da brauchen wir sicher drüber reden.
Doch, natürlich, ich würde gerne noch mal reden.
Weil die so Freak uns auf der Strasse anspricht.
Nee, nicht uns, dich. Du wurdest heute auf dem Weg in die Arbeit angesprochen.
Hey, du bist doch Stefan, kann ich ein Selfie mit dir machen? Wie hat sich das für dich angefühlt?
Es war ein schöner Moment. Es ist auch immer schön. Du findest es ja auch noch schön.
Du wurdest von deinen Verwandten vielleicht angesprochen, aber nicht von einem Fremden.
Ich fand diesen einen Moment mal sehr schön, wo meine Mutter mich auf der Strasse erkannt hat.
Ja.
Davor die drei Mal hat sie mich nicht erkannt, wollte sie mich nicht sehen. Aber jetzt schon. Jetzt hat sie mich erkannt. Ja, war ganz okay der Moment. Also, ich würde mir wünschen, dass man dann vielleicht einfach nicht spricht mit den Leuten, dass man nicht gezwungen ist, mit fremden Leuten auf der Strasse. Ja, mit Blicken arbeitet. Weil, okay, du erkennt dich ein bisschen, weil du viel auch aus deinem Leben erzählst und so, aber ich kenne ihn nicht, deswegen will ich nicht mit ihm reden müssen.
Und deswegen soll er mir einfach sagen, er soll auf mich zeigen, auf sein Handy deuten, dass er mich erkannt hat, ein Foto haben will, ein Foto mit mir machen, wie ich nicht grinse, als hätten wir die beste Zeit unseres Lebens und dann soll er gehen, einfach. Das wäre schön.
Und wäre es für dich okay, wenn er das jetzt veröffentlicht? Auf Tinder-Post oder so? Oder als Tinder-Profilbild nimmt?
Davon bin ich auch ausgegangen. Du möchtest sogar, dass es veröffentlicht wird? Nö, aber ich bin davon ausgegangen, dass er es tut. Weil ich meine, Selfie mit Angela Merkel gehe ich auch davon aus, dass ich das veröffentliche, glaube ich. Wow, da hast du gerade deinen Finger sehr tief ins Ohr gesteckt. Das war, uoi. Ist das so ein Trick, dass du dir eigentlich den Hinterk Kopf steckst, oder war das gerade echt? Nee, er war wirklich drin, komplett drin. In Niedersachsen wurde dann wieder ein Wolf gesichtet. Was sagst du dazu? Ich sag mal, gut, dass wir jetzt einen Todeslaser haben. Oh, Gag-Kategorien verbinden, nicht schlecht. Die Gag-Brücke. Brücke? Brücke. Ich habe noch einen Gag. Problem Wolf in Niedersachsen gesichtet, könnte aber auch ein Problem Schaf in einem Problem Wolf Pelz sein. Hm, nicht schlecht. Beide finde ich gut. Wenn ihr einen davon im Neo Magazin hört, dann wisst ihr. Ja, es wird aber nicht passieren, bei Florian hat noch nie einen Gag passiert. Money, money, money, money, das stimmt nicht. Einen. Aber das war kein... Ja, ja, ja, nee, nee, nee, so kommen wir mal nicht um die Ecke, mein Lieber. Ich finde auch interessant, wie unsere Humorfarben angefangen. Sich leger an eine eineinhalb Meter entfernte Wand lehnen, so in so einem dreissig Grad Winkel. Ja, weisst du, was ich auch noch machen wollte? Wie unnatürlich kann man sich in einem Gespräch mit Fremden eigentlich benehmen, sodass sie irgendwann sagen, also dass sie das Gespräch unterbrechen und einen auf die Situation aufmerksam machen. Ich glaube, es ist sehr schwer. Ich glaube, die Leute tolerieren sehr, sehr viel, bevor sie tatsächlich das rummachen. Und ganz auf den Boden setzen. Heute hat mich jemand angesprochen, da habe ich überlegt, kurz nach dem Handstein zu machen oder sowas. Also man plötzlich nicht rechnet einfach. Was ich mal ganz gerne machen würde, ist, wenn ich in den Raum komme und jemand sagt, setz dich, sich dann einfach da, wo man steht, auf den Boden zu setzen. Und dann, nee, nee, ich meinte auf den Stuhl. Ach so, okay, gut, und sich dann auf den Stuhl setzen. Habe ich aber mich noch nicht getraut, tatsächlich. Nee? Nee, weiss ich nicht. Mir fällt sowas in, ich bin, ich habe total viele Ideen für so socially awkward Situationen, aber wenn ich drin bin, dann denke ich immer nur, einfach nicht auf die Brüste starten, nicht auf die Brüste starten, nicht auf die Brüste starten und dann, ja, und dann natürlich auf die Brüste gestarrt. Ja. Aber das finde ich auch, also, ich finde, also man kennt ja, es gibt ja, wenn man mit Fremden spricht, oft die Situation, dass man denkt, ist der andere vielleicht geistig behindert. Ja, das passiert mir sehr oft. Und ich finde es lustig, dass man so Dinge macht, einfach die Hand ab und zu ruckartig nach oben streckt zum Beispiel, sodass der vor einem denkt, das ist eine Krankheit und man aber und dann quasi davon ausgeht, dass er diese Krankheit noch nicht kennt, aber akzeptiert, dass man diese Krankheit hat irgendwie, dass man anderen den Arm in die Luft streckt. Ja, ja. Aber man weiß ja selber, wenn man das macht, dass es die Krankheit wahrscheinlich nicht gibt und der gerade davon ausgeht, eine neue Krankheit entdeckt zu haben. Das hätte ich machen sollen vielleicht. Aber wahrscheinlich kann es gut sein, dass du sowas machst und einfach nie darauf hingewiesen wirst, dass du zum Beispiel in Konversationen die ganze Zeit den Kopf schüttelst oder deine Haare hin und her bewegst oder was auch immer oder deine Haare sich bewegen, weil man kann ja seine Haare auch bewegen, man hat ja Muskeln in den Haaren setzen und dass du es aber gar nicht merkst, weil Leute dich nie darauf hinweisen, weil sie einfach denken, das ist halt einfach Stefan. Ich habe auch mal überlegt, ob ich vielleicht so etwas wie Tourette habe, aber in diesem Moment, wo ich das mache, quasi nicht wahrnehme, weil mein Geist das irgendwie ausblendet. Ich also im Klassenraum früher ab und zu mal Ficker gesagt habe oder so. Tourette ist einfach lustig. Aber diesen Moment nicht wahrnehme, weil das irgendwie meinen Körper ausblendet und Leute halt nur mit mir befreundet sind, weil ich ihnen leidtue oder so. Hast du diese Gedanken auch schon mal gehabt? Ja. Ja. Seltsam, ne, aber kann ja echt sein. Ich überlege gerade was lustiger, wäre halt so das klassische Tourette mit Schimpfworten oder dass man was anderes sagt. Komplimente. Komplimente zum Beispiel oder halt einfach wirre, einfach nur Worte, Pfanne, Pfanne, einfach irgendwas sagt, was weird ist, weil das könnten die Leute wahrscheinlich noch viel weniger einordnen als Schimpfwörter. So, jetzt ist, äh, Freunde! Jetzt ist der Typ gerade da. Schöne Versuche, sowas halt. Was ich auch eine sehr lustige Idee fand, war, ähm, von Ted L. Nancy, übrigens das geile Buch, was wir beide empfehlen, Letters from Nut, wo er vorgibt, er schreibt immer quasi Briefe an fremde Unternehmen und so, wo immer lustige Briefe halt. Und in einem hat er behauptet, er hätte Tourette und hat halt quasi auch im Brief teilweise einfach, er hätte Namens Tourette oder so, einfach in Grossbuchstaben manchmal Adam, Janet, einfach sehr gross in Capital Letters die Namen ausgeschrieben. Was ich auch echt lustig fand, dass man das halt auch noch ins Geschriebene überträgt. Das ist schon echt genial. Vor allem, es ist, glaube ich, erstaunlich, wie viel die Leute ertragen. Ich bin ja auch gerade im Moment in einem hitzigen Gespräch, weil ich habe auf Ebay Stühle verkauft. Geht es immer noch weiter eigentlich? Ja, es geht tatsächlich noch weiter. Und ich bin leider momentan nicht in der ... Also ich habe Stühle verkauft und dann habe ich dem Käufer gesagt, du kannst sie jetzt eine Woche lang abholen. Wenn du sie nicht abholst, dann sind die in meiner Wohnung. Ich allerdings ziehe aus dieser Wohnung aus. Man muss also sagen, es stand nicht in der Auktion drin. Ja, ich weiss. Warum nicht? Weil ich wollte, dass mehr Leute sich melden. Für wie viel Geld wollte sie sich verkaufen? Das nennt man Betrug. Ja, ja, ja. Auf jeden Fall wurde... Das ist das Beste daran, dass es über dieser Geschichte für mich steht, dass du die ganze Zeit eine Straftat begehst einfach. Das ist einfach, dass du rechtlich den Kürzeren ziehst. Die Stühle wurden verkauft, der Käufer konnte sie aber nicht abholen, und jetzt sind sie in dem Keller der Wohnung, die mir mal gehört hat, jetzt aber nicht mehr, und ich kann nicht auf diese Stühle zugreifen. heisst, sie sind zwar an dem Ort, ich habe die Kontrolle über die Stühle verloren, ja, und kann dem Käufer deswegen die Stühle nicht überreichen.
Ja, danke, dass die Aufnahme einfach unterbringt.
Hey Kai, was gibt's?
Du dummes, dummes Ar...
Ich hab gesagt, das ist scheissegal.
Komm rein.
Welches Licht? Wo siehst du ein Licht? Du siehst Dinge, die nicht da sind.
Das ist nicht hier. Jetzt verlässt du jetzt einen Raum, bitte. Auf jeden Fall, die Stühle wurden verkauft, ich kann sie aber nicht holen. Und jetzt stehe ich im Kontakt. Und der Käufer auch nicht. Der Käufer kann sie auch nicht holen. Was das Problem ist. Das ist das Problem, das heißt, der Käufer muss jetzt auf eigene Faust dahinfahren, um Einlass erbeten oder dort einbrechen. Ich habe mir tatsächlich zum Einbruch geraten, was glaube ich nochmal eine Straftat ist. Anstiftung zum Einbruch, das ist ein bisschen problematisch. Na ja, Einbruch heißt in dem Fall bei Nachbarn Klingel, die einen freundlich bei den Keller zu haben. Ja, oder halt einfach gewaltsam einbringt, weil er muss nur durch zwei Türen durch und könnte sich dann einfach die saftigen Nektarstühle holen. Und dann wäre es das schon gewesen. Aber es geht nicht, weil ich habe die Kontrolle über die Stühle verloren. Das alles für Stühle, die nicht die sind, die du angeboten hast, die sind auch noch kaputt, muss man dazu sagen. Nur das Bild von Stühlen, das habe ich ihm noch nicht gesagt, es sind nicht die Stühle, die liegen nicht an ein geratenes Bild, aber das wird er wahrscheinlich selber noch irgendwann merken, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen problematisch und da finde ich es auch so lustig, wenn man in dieser Stühle, nein, Dübel habe ich das, habe ich mir geschrieben, diese Damn, Damn you Autokorrektur, Dübel wollte ich Ihnen verkaufen. Für 200 Euro wollen Sie Dübel, ja fünf Designer-Dübel.
Ja, und das ist ein bisschen problematisch. Und ich finde es so lustig, weil ich habe mit dem so extrem ernste Messages hin und her und immer alles in Caps und so, sie müssen dringend die Schüler abhalten und ich habe alle regelkonform, habe ich die geworben, jetzt will ich die auch haben und ich dachte mir, man schreibt mal so eine Antwort zurück und so, ja, die sind in meiner Wohnung, wo übrigens noch ein Brandfleck ist von der Party letztens, oh Gott, da hätten sie dabei sein müssen, wo der Jonas, die kennen ja Jonas, einfach mega lang ausschweift und einfach so einen seitenlangen Absatz hat, einfach abschweift und dann wieder zurückkommen, so, ja, nächste Woche können sie sie abholen. Ob man da irgendwie darauf eingehen würde, so, haben sie eigentlich einen Schaden, was schreiben sie für einen Scheiss? Ich glaube, man müsste wirklich viel machen. Man toleriert viel, glaube ich, in einem Gespräch mit Fremden. Extrem viel, extrem viel. Aber wie ist jetzt der Stand? Update mal bei uns kurz. Der Stand ist, dass er geschrieben hat, ja, können Sie bitte noch mal Ihre Adresse und Ihren Namen schicken. Und da wusste ich nicht, fuck, in welche Richtung geht das jetzt, weil er hat meinen Namen nicht tatsächlich. Und ich habe den Account auch nur erstellt für diese eine Auktion. Das heisst, eigentlich, glaube ich, hätten die relativ grosse Schwierigkeiten. Und ihr denkt, du heisst Feedline Punchline, Edgy. Feedline Punchline. Vielen Dank übrigens für die ganzen Mails, die mir die tollen Fans geschickt haben und die tollen Bilder und die tollen Links zu irgendwelchen. Es kamen lustige Bilder von irgendwelchen Horrorsaiten.
Das will ich nicht sagen, ich will die Leute nicht weitermutigen.
Nee, sag mal bitte.
Ist nicht so wichtig, aber irgendwelche Horrorbilder oder Nuttenbilder.
Mehr als fünf Bilder?
Scheiss doch, ist jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Vielen Dank nochmal an alle, die sich die Mühe gemacht haben, um irgendwelche Bilder rauszusuchen, die sie mir geschickt haben. Aber apropos Ebay, eine Kollegin von uns hat damals, als sie Geld brauchte, ungefähr im gymnasialen Alter, eine mega geile Idee gehabt. Und zwar hat sie ein Twilight-Buch gehabt und hat dann die Unterschrift von Robert Pattinson, so lange geübt, bis sie die perfekt konnte, hat das Buch unterschrieben und für sehr viel Geld bei Ebay verkauft. Also so auch im dreistelligen Bereich, wo ich mir denke, gehen jahre Ideen. Man kann einfach Geld drucken. Du kannst Geld einfach... Ja, es ist auch ein Lupenrein. Niemand kommt dir auf die Schliche. Du willst dir nicht beweisen, die Leute wollen ja keinen Nachweis, dass es wirklich so ist. Die Unterschrift kann einfach gefälscht werden. Nee, komm, die Leute wollen, dass hier echt ist. Es ist dieses Kunstfälscher-Prinzip. Ja, genau. Jeder in der Reihe, der Gewinn macht. Niemand will die Wahrheit, niemand verdient an der Wahrheit.
Genau, niemand verdient die Wahrheit, alle verdienen daran, an der Lüge und alle wollen dementsprechend auch, dass es eine wieder Wahrheit ist.
Und das ist so ein ganz interessant, also wenn man so eine Idee hat, finde ich, hat man auch das Geld einfach verdient.
Ja, absolut, aber ich frage mich, warum das nicht viel mehr Leute machen.
Und es gibt ja in Amerika zum Beispiel ein Autogrammmagazin, wo dann auch so die besten Autogramme, welcher Promi gibt die besten Autogramme und welcher Promi ist wie nett im Autogramme geben und wen lohnt es sich zu stalken, weil der gibt im Autogramme. Und da, glaube ich, gibt es dann auch Rubriken wie sind die wirklich echt und was zeichnet die einzelnen Leute aus. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon möglich, Autogramme so gut zu fälschen, dass man jetzt unter Nichtwissenschaftliche Analyse nicht eintritt. Mir kommt auch das Autogramm an. Also wenn Robert Pattinson jetzt nicht jemand mit seinen Kalligrafies-Set rausholt und so ganz filigran irgendwie sein Autogramm reinmeißelt, dann glaube ich, kriegt man das schon hin. Kannst du die Unterschriften deiner Eltern fälschen? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ja, ich auch. Aber ich habe die auch genau vor Augen, komischerweise. Ja. Ich habe die genau vor Augen. Man weiss ja nie. Also als Schüler ist es, also mittlerweile ist es nicht mehr so wichtig, aber als Schüler ist es extrem wichtig.
Kalligrafie ist extrem interessant und tatsächlich auch eine Wissenschaft, was ich bislang einfach nicht glauben wollte. Aber meine Mutter...
Ja, das heisst aber nicht Kalligrafie, das heisst anders.
Doch. Also die Wissenschaft der Schriftanalyse heisst anders.
Das weiss ich nicht. Graphologie heisst die. Ja. Und meine Mutter arbeitet im Personalwesen und tatsächlich hat sie eine Kollegin, die Leute einstellt, also eine Personalleiterin, Kollegin, die halt Leute einstellt, indem sie auch einen handgeschriebenen Lebenslauf erwartet und quasi das an einen Graphologen gibt, der diese Unterschrift, die Schriftart analysiert und anhand der Schriftart feststellt, gut, das ist eine Teamperson, die ist selbstbewusst und so weiter und daraufhin stellt sie dann Leute ein, wo meine Mutter auch sagt, so ein Crap, das würde ich niemals machen, was ich auch verstehe, weil es ist einfach so eine, es wirkt wie so eine Pseudowissenschaft, aber ich habe das im Internet mal gemacht, so einen Test, da musst du so einen Beispielsatz schreiben, so einen Goethe-Text oder so, und dann musst du dann halt so ein paar Fragen beantworten. Inhaltlich top, aber die Schrift ist scheiße. Genau, dann stellen sie Fragen zum Inhalt des Textes. Inhaltlich fantastisch, sehr, sehr gut. Sie sind sehr, sehr dumm, aber sie müssen ja in Schrift. Nee, dann musst du halt genau sagen, wie die Abstände sind zwischen den einzelnen Buchstaben, wie die in der Höhe variieren, wie der Abstand ist zwischen Grossbuchstaben und Kleinbuchstaben. Und es macht alles schon irgendwie so ein bisschen Sinn, weil du denkst, okay, extrovertierte Leute schreiben wahrscheinlich einfach grösser. Aber das haben wir auch gesagt. Ich habe immer eine sehr kleine Schrift und jemand hat auch immer gesagt, so nee, du darfst keine kleine Schrift haben, weil klein steht für schüchtern, nicht selbstbewusst und du glaubst nicht an das, was du schreibst. Vielleicht wenn jemand leise redet, man auch sagen kann, er glaubt nicht an das, was er redet, aber was auch Quatsch ist.
Weiß ich nicht, ja.
Weil man eigentlich häufig in den Situationen am lautesten redet, in denen man sich des Inhalts am unsichersten ist eigentlich, oder? Also habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht. Je unsicher ich bin, desto lauter werde ich. Ich weiß nur, dass ich sehr fest schrei, also ich habe eine wahnsinnig dicke Handschrift. Weil du immer sehr wütend bist. Ich versuche so das einzugravieren fast schon auf dem Blog.
Und das ist, glaube ich, so ein Zug für massive Probleme. Wir haben jetzt Zugriff auf ein bisschen Handschrift von unseren Hörern tatsächlich. Es geht ja mittlerweile auch um das Podcast-Ufo-Tagebuch, nicht Tagebuch, Poesiealbum. Freundschaftsbuch. Ich sage Poesiealbum, tatsächlich. Also würde ich dich bitten, sich daran zuführen, Freundschaftsbuch zu sagen. Ich habe ein Poesiealbum und mein bester Freund war damals echt ein Trottel, aber ich habe ihn geliebt, aber er ist ein grossartiger Typ. Und man muss ja mein Poesiealbum immer so ausführen und dann hat er mal noch so einen Freiraum, wo man noch so ein Gedicht reinschreiben sollte und sowas. Und ihm ist anscheinend nichts eingefallen und er hat einfach das Gedicht von der Seite davor, von einer anderen Freundin, einfach kopiert eins zu eins.
Und dann die Seitenzahl umgeschrieben, so dass seine davor war.
Und ich dachte mir, wie dumm hältst du mich, dass mir das nicht sofort auffällt, wenn ich es durchblätter und es einfach exakt dasselbe Gedicht nochmal.
Ja gut, gute Arbeit, aber das ist ein cooler Typ.
Wie heisst der?
Florian hieß der. Wir waren damals Florian und Florentin tatsächlich, die unbesiegbare Gang damals in Ebersberg. Die Flos, die beiden Flos. Die beiden Flos, ja. Er war Flo-Guy und ich war Teenie. Oh Gott. Mein Spitzname ist immer mehr Teenie. Teenie. Aber bist du stolz auf diesen Spitznamen, oder? Ja, geht. Ist okay. Besser als Flo tatsächlich, aber es gibt mittlerweile einige Leute, die mich Flo nennen, auch bei den Rocket Beans werde ich Flo genannt.
Glaubst du denn, dass ein Spitznamen was mit dir macht? Also ich hatte zum Beispiel nie einen Spitznamen.
Also mich wurde immer Stefan genannt. Stefan ist natürlich anders als Teenie, der sehr verniedlicht ist.
Ein relativ strenger Name dann, also ein männlicherer Name als Teenie.
Ich weiß noch nicht, also zu einem gewissen Grad ist es ja, wenn du rebellierst gegen einen Spitznamen, dass er sich dann noch weiter verhärtet. Also nicht nur, weil die Leute einfach es genießen, dich zu foltern, auch, aber auch einfach, weil es den Leuten bewusster wird und dadurch vielleicht eher im Gedächtnis bleibt. Also man einfach, aber kann man eigentlich, gute Frage, kann man selbst einen Spitznamen etablieren für sich selbst? So, ich will jetzt Spud genannt werden, Spud, also man nennt mich jetzt Spud, so übrigens, wer, Mann, Mann, also ich meine Spud. Ich bin auch der Meinung, dass ein Name viel mit einem macht, also ist ein anderes Thema also ist ein anderes Thema. Nur um erst oben würdest du sagen, oder was? Ich will nur gerade kurz deine Frage beantworten mit einem komplett anderen Topic. Bitte. Aber einer von unserem, von meinem damaligen Freundeskreis, der hieß M.Jünger und hat seinen Nachnamen halt wie Jürgen geschrieben. Und seitdem heisst wohl alle nur Jürgen genannt, was natürlich ein sehr anachronistischer Name ist und ich glaube, deswegen hat er sich auch einfach anders entwickelt als andere. Umgebracht letztendlich. Ja, letztendlich hat er sich irgendwann erhängt. Grüße. Liebe Grüße an die Familie. An seine Eltern. Ciao. Ich bin Stefan. Nee, finde ich okay. Kann gut sein, dass das was mit dir macht, wenn die Namen.
Ich gucke mich nicht so an, ich weiß weiß, ich habe auch nicht die anderen Antworten. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, Spitznamen ist ein sehr fremdbestimmtes Ding eigentlich. Ich glaube, man kann da nicht raus. Ich wollte mal früher in so einem Jugendlichen, da war ich echt sehr jung, da wollte ich, da habe ich gegoogelt, weil ich wollte unbedingt einen Spitznamen haben, weil alle Freunde hatten einen Spitznamen und Stefan gab es keinen Spitznamen. Da habe ich gegoogelt, was es für Spitznamen für Stefan gibt und Fanta war dabei. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay. Das ist Coco, das ist Bud und das ist Fanta. Und ich dachte, das macht Sinn für jemanden, der Fanta trinkt. Also habe ich angefangen, viel Fanta zu trinken und habe so gedroppt, nenn mich doch einfach Fanta. Und das war einfach so uncool und das hat sich nie durchgesetzt. Der uncoolste Move ist seinen eigenen Spitznamen etabliert. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich der uncoolste Move. Aber da war ich auch irgendwie acht oder so, das hat mich wahnsinnig cool gefühlt. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist euch aufgefallen, aber ich trage immer Bowling-Schuhe und viele Leute nennen mich Strike und falls ihr auch, also nennen mich ruhig Strike, ist kein Problem. Also helft mir vielleicht einfach. Also wegen den Bowling-Schuhen. Okay, cool. Also ciao, macht's gut, ich krieg gleich später. Aber noch mehr Gags in diese Richtung, wenn wir das Thema wechseln. Oder hättest du nicht lieber so einen Zwischennamen, so Stefan der Löffler-Titze oder sowas? Oder Stefan die Bohrmaschine-Titze. Gefahr. Also so ein Titel, oder? Bei mir wäre es, glaube ich, Gefahr. Stefan Gefahr Titzler. Weil ich stehe für Gefahr ein bisschen.
Ja.
Weil Leute, die mich sehen, haben sie ein bisschen Angst, weil ich relativ gross und sehr muskulös bin.
Gefahr, das Fahr steht für Stefan.
Auto.
Wo wir wieder beim ersten Gag der Folge wären, wann hat die erste Person Auto statt Automobil gesagt.
Damit ist der Kreis geschlossen.
Ich bedanke mich recht herzlich bei Stefan Titzl für diesen kleinen Ausflug.
Können wir schon wieder Fire Up machen?
Ich glaube wir machen Fire, Fire, Fire Up.
Wir minerieren es gerade. Ich werde die Musik noch gar nicht kommen.
Moment, gib mir noch eine Sekunde.
Fügst du noch kurz ein?
Weiter, ich muss ganz kurz kapieren.
Mann, ich habe die Spur immer nicht angelegt.
Jetzt, da ist sie doch.
Fantastisch, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Haut rein, wir sehen uns, bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut.
Und schreibt uns und hebt ab, hebt immer ab, warum müssen wir immer abheben? Wir müssen aber auch abheben. Wie bekannt müssen wir sein, damit wir kein unbekanntes Flugobjekt mehr sind?
Irgendwann sind wir aber noch das Podcast-Fo.
Wie viele Hörer brauchen wir, um das Podcast-Fo zu sein?
Ciao!